this morning French authorities
announced that a policeman who took the
place of a hostage during a terror siege
at a supermarket in southwest France has
died that raises the death toll and
Friday's attack to 4:15 others were
injured Roxana Saberi reports one of the
first police officers who raced to the
supermarket standoff Friday in the
French town of TREB was lieutenant
colonel our new belt rom french
authorities say he offered to take the
place of a woman that the gunman Redwan
lack team had kept as a human shield
when shots rang out police stormed the
store and killed lack team they found
two hostages dead and beltram with
gunshot wounds he died hours later
French president Emmanuel macron is now
praising the officer for his courage
saying in a statement in giving his life
to end the deadly plan of a jihadi
terrorist he fell as a hero French
authorities say Leck team began his
series of attacks in the nearby town of
Carcassonne stealing a car and killing a
passenger than wounding a police officer
out on a jog witnesses who escaped from
lack teams attack on the supermarket say
he claimed to be acting on behalf of the
Islamic state
this witness described him as agitated
with a handgun and a knife yelling
Allahu Akbar god is great
French authorities say during the
standoff flak team demanded the release
of Salah abdel-salam he's one of the
terrorists who took part in the Paris
attacks in November 2015 which killed
130 people
he's now in jail charged with terror and
attempted murder
france's top prosecutor Francois Molins
says lack team a 25 year old Moroccan
born French national was on a government
list of people suspected of being
radicalized for CBS this morning
Saturday Roxana Saberi
London